Speaking of specific prices, Grant quickly
realized that there was one small issue
that he hadn't dealt with yet. He hadn't
had a chance to think about how much his
products should cost. I randomly picked
the numbers $5 for wipers and $3 for a
nozzle but he's probably going to want to
make a little bit more money than that.
For some reason, his friends who had
promised to buy his products didn't seem
particularly worried about how much they
would cost. But he wanted to get closer to
crunching some numbers so he could figure
out what kind of fortune his Gleaming
Glasses products would give him. So right
now, we have this very general equation
that we came up with in the last quiz for
the total amount of money that Grant's
going to make, but as we can see there
aren't any numbers in this yet. What we
want to do is get the actual price of each
product to be involved in this equation in
some way. So what other information do we
already have about this situation? Well,
we learned that 36 people want to buy
glasses wipers. We also know that 11
people each want two nozzles. What we
don't know yet, is the price that Grant
should set for each product, a set of
wipers and one nozzle. Similar to what we
did before, let's pick one variable to
represent the cost per wiper set and
another variable to represent the cost per
nozzle. I think I'll pick w to represent
the cost per wiper set and I'll pick n to
represent the price per nozzle. Looking
back up at this equation we came up with
in the last quiz, let's just start by
focusing on the amount of money that
Grant's going to earn from selling wiper
sets. So for now, we're just going to
ignore the part of the equation about the
nozzles. So, which of these expressions
down here do you think should replace this
question mark? How much money is Grant
going to earn from selling wipers to 36 friends?